and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together back to the moon and Beyond
with fuel tanks filled NASA's Artemis
rocket launches with the aim to send
humans back to the lunar surface for the
first time in 50 years
well our science correspondent Thomas
Moore joins us live and Thomas there
have been a few false starts here
haven't they but they finally got it up
yes there were a number of full stars
because of technical problems but yes
they managed to get it off the ground
from a launch pad 39b at Kennedy Space
Center there was a long tail of flame
and a thundering crackle as the most
powerful rocket ever built went towards
the heavens and perched on the top is
the Orion spacecraft that will take
humans back to the moon for the first
time in in 50 years and that is
tremendous exciting not just because of
the science that they they will do there
but also because it is the first step on
on the way to Mars now that this is a
test mission the last test mission
before humans are on board is an
accelerated testing program uh under
Artemis as the name of the the space of
the current moon missions and it will
mean that humans could be back on the
lunar surface in just three years time